president-elect Donald Trump has been
listed as a threat to human rights by
the major human rights group Human
Rights Watch they released this yearly
world report about human rights concerns
in more than 90 countries around the
world they are now listing
president-elect Donald Trump as a threat
to human rights of course the trumpets
will say it's all fake news even though
this is a report that's been around for
many many years they said quote Donald
Trump selection is US president after a
campaign fomenting hatred and
intolerance and the rising influence
political parties in Europe that reject
universal rights have put the post-war
Human Rights system at risk what
specifically are they referring to most
sensible people can probably guess
massive deportation of immigrants
curtailing women's rights threats with
regard to media freedom threats to go
back to using torture threats to kill
the families of terrorist threats to
invade countries to extort oil confusion
about why nuking Europe would be bad
human rights wash actually said that
some politicians in Europe that are part
of the rise of the nationalist European
right combined with Trump could lead to
tyranny how ironic is it that the right
justifies ownership of weapons because
the government might become tyrannical
under of course Democrats and liberals
and socialists and communists and then a
key human rights group says hey it's
actually Trump who represents the risk
of tyranny in the United States and
people pretend it's all politics you
know anything negative about Trump is
just partisan this is an organization
that just looks at the facts and the
statements and issues a report about
that and of course Trump will tweet at
3am that Human Rights Watch simply can't
be trusted nobody respects human rights
more than me folks nobody trusts me or
something like that he hasn't tweeted it
yet but this is a trustworthy and
reliable organization and a report that
has been published for many years now
with significant specificity about the
threats they claim exists oh but give
him a chance David yeah I really I
really agree with her any Sanders at
stake on this which is that when it
comes to trade policy outsourcing
infrastructure we're willing to have a
discussion they're willing to negotiate
and talk with them but when he when he
goes to xenophobia and races
and sexism we're not going to have a
discussion on that well we shouldn't but
that's the problem it's scandal after
scandal and insane comment after stand
same comment to such a degree that
everything becomes normalized well
people say well we'll just negotiate
about the Muslim ban or about whatever
issue it is that we're talking about and
Trump is going to really have no option
but to just slam the organization Human
Rights Watch it's fake news set up by
the Chinese to make Trump look bad and
George Soros is paying each of their
employees 1,500 bucks to write bad about
Trump or something like that I don't
know how he'll explain this away but
this is a very very serious situation
that we have and it's not just Trump
right Trump is part of the problem but
the rise of right-wing nationalism in
Europe is also part of the problem and
we've talked about that Trump has mocked
a fallen soldier's family Trump is
mocked a disabled reporters disability
Trump bragged about sexually assaulting
women he is a threat to human rights
isn't he during the campaign there was
this idea that he's using this rhetoric
to appeal to that group of people but he
doesn't actually believe in that and
when he's president he's not going to
put those kind of policies in place but
now when we see that there's this idea
of having a Muslim registry in the works
yeah that's very concerning yeah which
he still hasn't said definitively
whether it's happening or not but we had
people you know advisors close to him
saying oh yeah they're making plans for
it it's really bad and at a certain
point we have to believe that the
candidate at least wants to do what
they're saying they're going to do I
know that people say well he said X or Y
to appeal to group Z that may be but if
people are voting for him for that
reason you would think that at least to
some extent they would try to hold him
accountable and hold him to his word and
that he's going to try to do the things
that he said he's going to try to do if
your only defense is Trump lied about
what he was trying to do in order to get
votes all you're admitting is that you
voted for a liar and that's not really a
great defense of the person that that
you helped elect thanks for watching
this video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the david pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much
she ate it